こんにちははじめした超です2年ほど前の話でしょうか
クリスマスの日に僕の家にストーカーの方が入り込んで事件になった話があったと思う
んですが私がこのように住んでいてあの事件とは別にも数々のいろんな方が家に来る
ことがありました今回の動画ではその中でも特に僕の中の記憶にのっ
持っているあの人はストーカーだったのかはたまたストーカーズはなかったのかという
非常に絶妙の狭間なんで僕は何とも言えないんですけどもそんな何とも言えない事件が
起きたことを今日は皆さんにお話ししようと思います
これから4事件が起きたのは
いつか忘れました大変な傘って気がしますね今誰だもう時効というか結構日が経ってる
からまぁ言っちゃっても大丈夫かなと思ってるんですけどもやっぱりですね色んな人が
家に来るわけですよおそらく3年ぐらい前だった気がするんですけども
あちょっとモーゼ強い感じでいきますね町地私肇社長は外で動画を撮影している機器
愛のボークはちゃったーーーーの近くで動画を撮っていました
その日は天気が悪くポツポツと雨が降り始め日が暮れる頃には大雨に変わっていたの
です撮影が終わり
僕は家の中に戻って動画編集しようとしていると家の外から
一人の女性がすいませんと私に
声をかけ
覚えてねーな思い出音が3年前だからうっすらんですよね
あ
戻りますすいませんと声をかけられ当時の私はまだ心が優しく
まあ今も優しいんですけどより優しく困っている人がいると放っておけない性格だった
のです
まあ今もそうなんですけどどうしましたかと聞いてみるとその女性はイトーヨーカドー
はどこにありますか
そう私に声をかけてきたので話を聞くとその女性駅から降りて歩いて物の近くまで来て
いたのですが駅からイトーヨーカドーは私の家の真逆の方向にあるのです
親は私は一瞬怪しいと思いながらも話を聞いてみると
[音楽]
なんですよ麻疹記憶が正しければそういういく d いうとかあんまり深く聴くとよく
ないなと思って特に理由は聞かなかったですけど
その除染はイトーヨーカドーに行きたいと言っていましたそして私はその女性にイトー
ヨーカドーへの行き方を教えるとその女性は
顔を曇らせ私を車で送っていってくれません
そう私に言ったのです私は完全に怪しみました
行けば普通に歩いていけばいいやと言いたいところだったのですがその女性姉のせいで
服が
ビッシャビシャに濡れていましたみなさんの想像する
ちょっと濡れた感じではなくもう神の結果な服までビシャビシャに濡れててどうし
ようって
なっちゃう感じのタイプでした私の記憶が正しければコミュ二ティファールを買って
タオルを上げて
で笠間を渡したんですけども好投の生き方とか私はイトーヨーカドーにいけないスマホ
の電池も切れている
なんとかして私をイトーヨーカドーまで送ってくれませんかと言われ私はとても悩み
ますこの人は本当に困っているのだろうか
いやでもイトーヨーカドって真逆じゃねうちの図書暴れてるしなめっちゃ濡れてた本当
に迷ってるのか
角でピンポイントで鬱に来て知らない人に来るまで乗せてってくれませんかっていう
のってちょっと怪しいなと思ったしてがタクシー使えば翌年といろいろ考えたんです
けどこの話を踏まえこの情勢に関する特徴的な部分が4つほどありますが一つ目
木
適地が駅と正反対の方向にこれは非常に怪しいポイントだなと思いました僕のじゃない
イトーヨーカドーと同じ方向とが近くであればまぁ全然は不自然ではあるんですけども
まぁ理にはかなっているかなと
右手が駅から見てイトーヨーカドーが真逆なんでそれでうちにピンポイントミクが
ちょっと怪しいなとか思った部分があったなと
二つ目めちゃくちゃ濡れてい
ましたこれは何かも人として何とかしてあげなきゃって思っちゃったんで
タオルとか買ってあげたんですけど天気予報を見ると10基本いたらもうわかるだろう
なとか思ったり傘買ってから来なよとか
さあ損益からイトーヨーカドーが遠いので濡れてるのも怪しいなとか思ったりはします
私でちょちょっと考えていいかもしれないですけど3つ目
伊藤洋子
どうまで送ってくださいこれがちょっと僕は怪しいなと思いましたねなんで俺が
まあ普通の考えではですよ僕だと知らない人の車に取ることはまずありえないして見ず
知らずの人に乗せてってくれませんかなんでも
無理だしてそれなのにピンポイントでうちに来てそういうことを言ってるって事はまず
べ中ストーカーでいかないんですけど何かセラそういう夜陰に来ようとしている人なの
かなという基盤しました4つ目
その後いろいろな状況を見てまぁ僕も動画編集しなきゃいけないし前期もめちゃくちゃ
嬉しその方も即びしょ濡れルナが弱ってたんで何とかしなきゃと思って結局は車の
すくってバーッと言ってしてよいということで落ちたんですけどイトーヨーカドーに
その女性を送って降りる瞬間
本当にありがとうございました私お礼がしたいので
これどうぞといえば1枚の手紙をもらいました内容を見ると
連絡先となにかしらの形で大礼をしたいので
今後よかったらご飯でもどうですかという内容の手紙でした
なんで助けられる前提でその手紙を持っていたのでしょう
そこで私は気づいてしまいました
コード1各 c 版だということをという話が舌版有りましたと
いやーなんか残念前だからなんてすごい学ぶ僕もちゃらんぽらんしてて家に来るとに
まだちょっと優しかった時期だったんで今だったら絶対しないです今だったらとなって
いることきても誰もすぐ計画の彼の翼対処するんですけど
まあ実は昔そういうことがあったなと思ってロット今回お話ししてみます
したまあもちろんなんですけどもらった手紙あそのまま処分させていただいてその年が
その後一切何もなかったんですけどなんか今なら言えるんですけどちょっとやり方が
ずるいなというか
あっつけダレ前提で手紙まで書いてますからねたぶん僕がそうやってくれるって言うの
を用意して打つまで来てたのかなって僕だと思っちゃいましたまあ真相は分からないで
けどもし本当にそういう目的で来ているのであればめっちゃ計算高いなぁと思ったと
いう話でございますた
すごくないってーところが真逆にあるわけだし濡れてるからもうそれ心配になりしその
1お金もないしスマホも電源切れてる子っていうも何もないからなんかそろそろ多分
やった人も忘れてるんだろうなぁと思ってちょっと動画にさせていただきましたそう
いうこととかあってねもう僕は思ったん性は優しいだけだと損するぜ
me
バッハ